[Music]
we're gonna go to jessica in san antonio
jessica are you there now
yes sorry here can you hear me yes i
screwed up the buttons i was hitting all
the wrong buttons
no you're fine i'm all fired up after
that last call i can't stand it when
schools don't help out kids hey so
what's up
um
my question is how do i know if my
marriage is over or
just a light question among friends
yes just very light you know i'll wait
i'll let you pour your wine
[Laughter]
dude
i don't know that wine's gonna cut it on
this one so why are you asking that
question
um i don't really even know where to
start but
i guess i'll start about three years ago
i became a stay-at-home mom i love my
kids like that is i just i love being a
stay-at-home mom everything is good
and me and my husband had a great
marriage before i worked he worked
everything was good
and then as soon as we moved and i
became a stay-at-home mom it was like
everything flipped and
i just don't know if it's even
i don't even know if i can come back
from some of the things that have
happened the last three years would have
happened
rattle them off for me
okay well um
no explanations just rattle them off
okay um he has accused me of being a
mooch and then i'm only after his money
that i need to be a better mother that i
can't handle our kids and that's why i
send them to school not because it's a
state law but i sent him to school
because i can't handle my children
that i can't clean the house good enough
he will not eat any dinner that i make
because i'm not a good enough cook we
haven't had sex in over four or five
months now
um he comes home he won't look at me he
won't talk to me uh i can't even have a
conversation with him
everything i do is not enough i also run
two small businesses and i'm studying to
get my real estate license and that is
not enough for him i can't do any more
and i just i don't know i'm to the point
to where he told me to leave a few
months ago and
i left and i came back after the weekend
and i'm wondering why i even did that
because i just
when is enough enough and are my
feelings even justified because i know
there's so many other marriages out
there that
are far worse than mine you know and
he's not mean to me because he doesn't
even talk to me
you know but he doesn't abuse me he
doesn't do anything but at the same time
i mean
i want a marriage i want a partner i
want someone to raise my kids with he
does nothing with our children he comes
home
drinks his beer passes out on the couch
and he's done with life
and i don't i don't want that i want
someone there i want a conversation i
want someone to be interested in what me
and the kids are doing i want him to
go to the holidays with us i do all of
that by myself and he stays home and i
want i want a partner and i'm just i'm
tired of
trying to figure out if he's the partner
i used to have anymore
i think that was it
so
that would have been awesome if you'd
exhaled
real big and then you had like a round
two
that would have been incredible
and i still have a round two but
so
when did he start cheating on you
that's what i'm wondering
i'm asking you you know when did it
start
oh gosh i feel like it has been going
for a really long time and that's i
don't know i do not know because
you know
when did it start uh i feel like it
started because he moved here before me
and my kids did okay and i think it
started there
i think something happened i don't know
if he's still doing it but something's
killing him inside and
have you talked to him about it
um i've asked him before and
when it when i talk to him about stuff
like this it's like i can see his eyes
he shuts down and he'll just tell me i
can't talk about this right now
or i can't deal with this and so that's
kind of how our conversations go
like it's not really
it's
there's no back and forth you know what
i mean
do they happen
do they happen in the in the context of
another fight
no
maybe let me let me put it this way
sometimes and by sometimes i mean almost
always couples get into arguments
and that turns into the
i think you're cheating on me
and that's when somebody goes i can't
have this conversation now shut down
that's different so the way i like
that's like me lifting weights like i'm
doing squats in my gym
at my house and then my wife comes up
while i'm in the middle of doing squats
and she's like hey by the way i'm going
to throw some kettlebells on your
shoulders and you can do some shoulder
presses too
like i i can't do everything you know
what i mean so
the only way
here
your marriage is over let me say that
yeah what you had is over and you know
that you didn't you didn't need some
idiot podcaster to
to confirm that for you
what you have to let me say this the the
marriage that as you once knew it is
over
the choice you have now is
do you want to rebuild something new and
better and stronger and more awesome
and do you have a partner to do that
building with
or are you going to accept every single
signal he's given you telling you i
don't want to be in relationship with
you anymore
i know
i'm
the thing that's holding me is the kids
i don't
what do you think what do you think
they're experiencing you didn't break up
anything
your husband broke it up i'm thinking
i'm like they don't they don't even know
what a relationship looks like they
don't have their dad because he's never
here and whenever he is off
somewhere else and they don't have their
mom
let's be clear
you're gone too
yeah you haven't been you for a long
time
and you can say you're not being abused
he's not hitting you i think neglect is
one of the worst evils you can do to
somebody because you're there in
body but you're not there in spirit
yeah and that starves people
at least when you're gone you're off
with your girlfriend or with your other
boyfriend i know where you are
yeah but when you're sitting in front of
me or next to me and you're not present
i don't know where you are it's
disorienting
it's it's
it's i i think it's evil
and so i think neglect is abuse
but that's just me and i'm just a
podcaster so what do i know
and i'll tell you
comparing your marriage to all the other
marriages out there and they've got it
worse that doesn't help anybody don't do
that yeah
if i'm you
i would
wait back up why did he tell you why did
he kick you out why do you tell you to
leave
he accused me of stealing money from him
did you
no
i paid the bills
how dare you jessica
gosh well that's what i was like i'm
paying the bills go look at the bank
account i'm not stealing money from you
to go on this lavish shopping spree
how old is he
36
okay
so the compassionate part of me which
isn't
i always want to try to see the other
side of the situation
he's done something he's doing something
he's something has happened to where he
is no longer the man he once was
yeah
and he has chosen to exit your
relationship but still sleep in the same
bed
oh he don't even sleep in the same bed
we haven't slept in the same bed in
almost four years then why are you
calling me and asking me if your
marriage is over
because i don't know what to do
god almighty at least bring beer over if
you're going to ask me like this
what are you doing
i don't know
i don't know i don't
i love them i don't want to
oh gosh i don't even know how to
describe it you know and i don't
sometimes don't think you you for sure
know how to describe it you're choosing
not to
i just i don't know if his issues come
from his parents marriage doesn't matter
i know it doesn't matter who cares where
they come from they are how do i even
get through to him like is there even
but i feel like i've tried everything
that i can and now it is the only thing
that's left for me to do is seriously
just pack my crap
and go why doesn't he pack his
it's where you and the kids live
because i feel like i can't tell him to
get out of his house i mean
why are you why are you using that kind
of pronoun language it's y'all's house
y'all are married y'all have kids
y'all pay the bills you have a job he's
got a job
i know i know i know i just just feel so
awesome
i'm just being weak about it
[Music]
i you hear me say this all the time and
it rings differently when i say it
directly to somebody jessica you are
worth more of a life than the one you
are allowing yourself to live
okay you are worth more than that god
help me your kids are worth more than
that your husband's worth more than that
and he has divorced you inside your own
home and he's too much of a coward to do
anything else
you're right on that and he's divorced
you and he's trying to make you the bad
guy and he's willing to outwit you
forever you know why he's got the magic
key beer
yes
well i guess i know
where to go from here
i will never ever tell somebody to get
divorced ever i know you're not but i
just needed i'm never gonna tell
somebody
to
can i ask you a hard question
yes do you not have girlfriends you've
sat down and had this conversation with
yes i do what do they tell you
they tell me pretty much exactly what
you're telling me
so why is it hard like what what's so
terrifying about the next step
have to do it i mean
there's really no return
there's no second guessing on that once
i say it it's done it's out there
and
i hate doing this to my kids
you didn't
you didn't
you get you can't say that you can't
think that
it sounds like you have worked really
hard
to stay married
are you perfect in this probably zero
percent chance you're perfect in this i
know you're not
is that fair
no
yes yes no i don't know
yes
no one is perfect in a marriage
relationship none of us i know
that's what i don't know am i doing
something
is there something that i should be
doing different that
well clearly if you would cook better
and clean the house more and be a better
mom and stop mooching off your husband
well yeah all the stuff would fix it you
see what i'm saying it's insane it's
nuts yes
so if i'm you here's and you're safe
physically here's the what i would do
i would ask my you've heard me say this
a thousand times it's like it's like the
the meta solution it solves nothing
but it provides an environment where
solutions can happen
i would
tell my husband we need to have a
truth-telling conversation
and we're going to schedule it for this
saturday
and you will make child care
arrangements
and
you need to talk about the future of
your relationship of your marriage and
of your time together
and i would tell him this isn't a fight
this is two old friends we just need to
go talk
and
the whole conversation will be a risk
he could not show up
he could say i'm not going i'm not going
to have this conversation i'm not
talking to you
um
and if that's the case then i think you
let him know it's your expectation then
that um if he wants to divorce you he
needs to go ahead and file
yeah
and you can say
um i've worked with a couple recently um
privately
that the
one of the spouses said to the other i
will never file
so if you want out you're gonna have to
do it and they did
and i think um that was hard for
everybody
yeah but they'd been backed into a
corner where one person was just really
trying to get the other person to do it
because they didn't want to pull the
trigger and the other person just said
i'm not going to so then finally
but there was just a truth telling
here's the moment we are in
yeah but i would have things written
down
and say we haven't had sex in six months
you tell me i disgust you you don't talk
to me
you tell me i don't cook well you tell
me i'm a mooch you accuse me of stealing
when i pay the electric bill
i get these
every one of your signals says that you
are done with this marriage are you done
with this marriage
he told me that he wasn't
whenever i left last time
he said that he wanted his family back
but
i mean nothing's changed so i think
you get back and say okay nothing has
changed
what does getting your family back mean
and it's gonna start with him coming
clean i'd be willing to bet
not a lot of money cause i don't have a
lot of money but i'd be willing to bet
he's cheated on you at some point if
he's not already
this whole thing feels like infidelity
just don't know if he'd ever come clean
with it i wish he would because i feel
like it would be a huge relief tell him
if he would
tell him can i just text him right now
nope
you cannot text any of this stuff i know
got
it will you let me know how the meeting
goes
i will
i promise you i will let me know how the
meeting goes and be prepared for it to
go
terribly
i know it could be a disaster or it can
be two adults having a really hard
conversation and this can be the
breakfast that changes everything
okay and what i'll tell you is i've had
two or three of these in my marriage
and they've so far all been great
the conversations weren't great they
were hard
but we just turned the lights on and
said let's we got to take inventory
because this track doesn't work
okay
okay so i'm not telling you it's over
i'm telling you no i know
he's he's all but left you he's done
yes
he's been done for a while now that's
right
that's right cool
you're brave you're brave you're brave
i know
no more no more saying i'm doing this to
my kids
this has been done to you and to your
kids and now it's time to stand up and
say i'm worth a better life than this my
kids are worth a better life than this
my husband's worth a better life than
this and we get to choose
are we going to have a good marriage are
we going to choose to not have a good
marriage are we going to choose to not
have a marriage at all
those are all choices
choose wisely